[Music]
how intense was the training and what
was the hardest part about it the
hardest part of all or always is is
maintaining the diet you know because
you just don't get to eat all the fun
things you want to eat and also eating
an enormous amount because this is my
natural body size I'm pretty skinny guy
and I was probably about 20 pounds
heavier than my body naturally wants to
be so it's a full-time job to keep that
muscle on so I just you know it's kind
of boring but just go to the gym a lot -
I did an enormous amount of pull-ups
pull-ups was like the staple of pull-ups
and dips I like to keep it we're doing
contests in between takes a little bit I
mean you could describe as contests when
one person is so superior I'm not sure
how much of a contest it is you yeah
jaqen no guys strong guys strong he
likes to stay fit and so it was nice on
set because he has like a little like he
creates a little area for exercise every
day just to keep himself his energy
going it's hard on these big films where
I'll be downtime of like two hours
sometimes three hours while they're
doing a lighting setup for something so
we got busy during that time and the
shops and get those push-ups and Charlie
Hunnam was one of the toughest guys on
set for King Arthur but originally
director Guy Ritchie did not want him
for the role Panem actually flew himself
to London and asked for a meeting with
Ritchie he convinced him to give him an
audition he was very concerned about my
size was that was the big issue on the
film because I'd lost an enormous amount
of weight for the last season the sons
so I showed up very very skinny and he
wanted someone who was sort of
physically imposing for in the role I
said listen mate if you're that nervous
about this
there was three other actors auditioning
for the role that day like you know big
well-known actors and I said why don't
you just bring mold in here and we'll
fight and whoever walks out the room
gets the role and and I think that's the
moment he's sort of like that Moxie I
saw a little twinkle as I said I the
friendship became real destroy where
those other three guys because I should
have said I couldn't say hahaha
you could probably find out I'd love to
know any hints um one of them wears a
cape
oh Henry Cavill okay maybe
[Laughter]
[Music]